with all the diversity of objects in
space
it might come as a bit of a shock if one
were told that it's actually our solar
system that is one of the most
unusual places in the cosmos
besides it is the only place in the
universe more or less explored by us
which is home to developed life forms
that we know of
our home galaxy is also a stellar system
with the biggest number of planets
can there be any other star out there
with the same number of planets as our
sun observations show that there is
it is the star kepler-90 with eight
planets orbiting it already detected
the discovery of this object was made
with the kepler space telescope
whose mission was to look for exoplanets
the kepler star system became the 90th
object spotted by the telescope
that is where the catchy nickname
kepler-90 comes from
let's take a closer look at it kepler-90
is a yellow dwarf of spectral type
g0v both its mass and radius
are approximately 1.2 times those of the
sun
as for the surface temperature it equals
6080 kelvin
or 5800 degrees celsius
the estimated age of the star is 2
billion years
this makes it 2 times younger than our
sun which formed about 4.6 billion years
ago
it was possible to gauge the star's age
by analyzing its spectrum
which helps establish the stage of the
star's evolution
another method instrumental for the
purpose is observing
stars lying closest to the object under
scrutiny
incidentally kepler-90 is too dim to be
seen with the naked eye
its luminosity meanwhile is
approximately 1.7 times as intense as
that of the sun
located in the draco constellation it is
approximately 2840 light years away from
our system
incidentally the object is hardly
notable for its properties
it is quite an ordinary main sequence
star without
any particularly exciting features it's
the number of planets discovered
in its system so far that makes it
really stand out
the only other system where we could
observe as many as eight planets
had been only our solar system before
kepler-90 had been spotted
the sun held the first place in terms of
the number of planets
with the following champions as the
runners-up the system's trappist-1
hd-10180 and hr-8832
each of them has seven detected planets
at first glance
kepler 90 might probably look like our
solar system
in miniature however on closer
inspection
the following principal differences will
change the observer's mind about it
for a start the smaller planets are
closer to the star
with the bigger planets lying further
and following bigger orbits
as we know it's quite the other way
around in the solar system
with the giants close to the star and
the smaller planets located further away
admittedly it is too early to claim this
with absolute certainty
and the number of planets we know of in
the kepler-90 system may increase
as scientists make progress in their
observations
another principle difference from our
system shows in the planet's mutual
proximity
the earth and the other planets in our
system on the other hand are located
further away from each other
and also all the eight known planets in
the kepler-90 system
orbit their star within just one
astronomical unit
another important difference is the fact
that six internal planets in the
kepler-90 system
are either super earths or mini neptunes
in size
while its two outer planets are gas
giants
the two planets in the system lying
closest to their host star
dubbed kepler-90b and kepler-90c
may probably be called our earth's
analogues however their temperatures are
considerably higher than on mercury or
venus
that is the two planets closest to their
host star in our solar system
this is the case on account of their
proximity to their system's center
kepler-90g and kepler-90h
are the objects lying furthest from
their parent star
both of these bodies are gas giants
their dimensions must be comparable to
those of jupiter
the system leaves the general impression
of being extremely compact
even kepler-90h the remotest planet in
the system
lies approximately as far as the earth
does from the sun
also as i've already mentioned this
remotest planet
is also the largest in the system and a
year on it is almost as long as a year
on our earth
331 days to be more exact
all these planets were discovered not so
long ago
with the latest of them kepler-90i
spotted as recently as in 2017.
it was possible to detect it with the
transit method that is by observing
sharp changes in the host star's
luminosity
when one or several planets pass across
its disk and block a certain portion of
its rays
normally visible to us this method is
quite productive for large celestial
objects lying close to a star
however if a planet is remote from it
fluctuations in the star's luminosity
and other incidental factors interfere
with observations
these problems may be dealt with in two
ways
namely by prolonging observation periods
and by sorting data with the help of
statistical algorithms and artificial
intelligence systems
in fact the latter helped the team of
scientists studying kepler-90
in discovering the eighth planet in the
system
a specially trained neural network was
instrumental in pinpointing one more
planet in the kepler-90 system
and defining its parameters
the newly spotted object was given the
temporary designation kepler-90i
located between kepler-90c and d
this celestial object orbits its star
within less than 15 days
and its radius is 1.32 that of the earth
kepler-90i is three times closer to its
star than mercury is to the sun
that is why its surface temperature is
rather high
approximately 427 degrees celsius
just to compare this value is quite
close to the surface temperature
venus which is 477 degrees celsius
kepler-90i resembles our earth very much
in terms of its chemical composition
size and mass its orbital period
is 14.4 earth days as the planet lies
too close to its parent star
it cannot realistically support life the
discovery of this celestial object
prompted a lot of questions on the part
of the scientific community
it still remains to be found out how
such a large and complex planetary
system
managed to remain so compact and stable
at the same time
also astronomers assume there might be
more planets out there orbiting
kepler-90
which still remain to be discovered the
search for other bodies in this system
is still
on as for the other known planets in the
system
the parameters of each are unique in
their own way
let's have a look at them starting with
the planet closest to its star
the radius of the one nearest to its
parent star
kepler-90b measures about 1.3 times that
of the earth
and its orbital period lasts for 7 days
just like all the other objects in the
system except kepler-90i
it was detected back in 2013.
the planet coming next orbiting its
parent star slightly further away than
kepler-90b
is kepler-90c its radius is slightly
smaller
measuring 1.19 times that of the earth
and as for its orbital period
it is 8.7 days
the fourth known object in terms of its
closeness to its star
is kepler-90d with its radius measuring
2.87 times that of the earth it orbits
kepler 90 within a period of 59.7
earth days kepler-90e
holds the fifth place its radius is 2.66
that of our planet
and its orbital period may reach 91.9
days
kepler-90f comes next
its radius is 2.88 times that of the
earth
and its orbital period is 124.9
earth days after kepler-90f
comes kepler-90g with a radius measuring
8.1 times that of the earth
its orbital period is 210
days and its mass is approximately 0.8
times that of jupiter
last but not least but definitely the
remotest from its star at this point
kepler-90h has a radius measuring 11.3
times that of the earth
its orbital period is 331.6
earth days and its mass is about 1.2
times that of jupiter
as this object's orbit lies
approximately as far from its star as
that of the earth from the sun
assumptions about the presence of
hypothetical moons in its environs may
prove to be true
if there are any located close to
kepler-90h
that are similar to titan or ganymede in
their parameters
conditions on these moons may be
realistically suitable for life
these hypothetical celestial objects
might have some really incredible
features
as their planet lies in the habitable
zone of its star
some of these moons may well resemble
our earth
for all we know just as you are watching
this video
on the cosmo channel a new life may be
dawning on a moon of the faraway gas
giant
[Music]
kepler-90h
you